hello and welcome to this video playing
bar chess 76 I got a French exchange
let's see how black defends that sir
this is an ambitious line it's not
really good to be honest like one of the
things you look forward to when you play
them play the exchange that they play
over ambitiously
I can I can start with this and then
canceling no now my idea is to play
Knight to e5 it's just a funny situation
yeah outside of my window I'm sorry
and in 95 yet why do they stumble into
that I had the same thing happening like
some some days perform I mean if you
play Bishop g4 you should have some clue
what you're doing 95 is the obvious
threat down because of that Bishop on g6
black should play f6 maybe Queen e8
those moves are a playable for black
you're not equalizing anymore but yeah
you're definitely able to put up a fight
okay so I had almost the same thing
recently but in that recent game one key
difference was that a head I had the
rook on day two and this is not the case
here
okay so why am I not just taking on c6
what is this what is the problem is
there a problem I don't see it let's
take it on King de 7 there is Knight
takes d5 I guess that was for some
reason not that was not winning in the
game I had some days ago because I had
ruined it - in that game was was funny
yeah that's a French exchange 14 moves
and you're completely winning it's not
it doesn't happen like every game of
course so here I'm Queen B 5
Queen b5 check rook b6 night takes d5
looks like it's killing I don't see why
not
there's no check and rupee 590 x7 it's
like everything hangs for black and the
rook is hanging and I'm attacking the
bishop and it's a full rook it's not
protected yeah hooray
yep frederik changed 1:0 in 18 moves ya
know what's funny a bit I got so much
feedback from that suggestion of the
French exchange like okay this is
nonsense and you're playing for a draw
and so on and I know I keep winning
games with it very easy win sort so okay
we got this and in that game that I
mentioned that I had recently my
opponent played this move then we had a
wicked d2 Knight f6 a3 96-95 which is
very comparable of course and my
opponent back then played this and we
got to this position and here funny
enough like 95 did not work due to a
queen or a queen ESX or something or d6
are now 26 seems better according to the
engine that's an important line if we
now compare with the actual game Knight
f6 Knight e5 by the way that is what
black should do
and then white will play like a 392 F
for you should be to widest a bit better
simply got more space and easier plans
sometimes even get a King side attack
with the knight coming to b3 Queen B 5
and so on but okay Knight f6 95 already
was very difficult for black as you see
the engine is struggling to recommend
anything that it is that it's not above
one one point plus for white and 94 take
take take and now King bee 7 you can
simply take and it's over now
the queen is just attacked this is made
that is that that would would be less
identical to the game that I had but in
my game Queen e6 was possible when the
night was hanging and the rook was
hanging on the tool and here this is not
an issue at all
you can simply um yeah I can simply do
this when in my game Queen a tool was a
possibility a tap on a three so little
things but him yeah yeah black is
already toast to King bees rook t3i
considered yes but critics e6 is such an
easy solution route III seems to window
I mean just take the pawn but once it's
just just clearly better for white yeah
rooty success is just just losing and
certainly I think for for the game ends
now okay it does not have to blunder the
rook of course can go here in such a
position is just winning got two points
and enter Bishop am just just a simple
win yeah you get you get those lines I
mean this is this is simply not good I
mean black is really struggling to keep
an equal game after this move and you
keep getting it people play over
ambitiously against the exchange French
all the time yeah thanks a lot for
watching